What do you imagine when I say ‘the future
of human evolution?’ A superbeing with powers
beyond comprehension? A mutated oddity far
removed from our idea of humanity? Or perhaps
nothing but decaying remains left in the wake
of our extinction? Scientists and sci-fi authors
have long speculated on what our future selves
will look like — and as technology advances,
our species might evolve much faster than
natural selection would typically allow. So,
for this entry into the archive, we’ll explore
posthuman scenarios from the absurd to the
frighteningly plausible — and meet the many
possible successors to humankind… Let’s
say hello to our first potential offspring.
I hope you’re excited… to meet Graham.
Graham is a distant descendant of humanity
whose body has evolved to survive car crashes.
Despite appearances, he isn’t a CG model,
but a life-sized statue made of silicon and
real human hair. Graham was created by artist
Patricia Piccinini, a sculptor known for her
hyper-realistic depictions of altered humanoids.
If you’ve seen clickbait on the internet
of human-animal hybrids, chances are the image
was actually one of her sculptures. Her work
can be disarming, unsettling — yet there’s
an unmistakable tenderness to each piece,
a humanity that underscores her themes of
bioethics and future evolution. Unlike Piccinini’s
other statues, Graham was created as part
of a road safety campaign, and comes with
his own website that allows you to look under
his skin and study the anatomy beneath. Graham’s
fictional biology is shockingly detailed.
His skull has evolved crumple zones to absorb
impacts, his neck is encircled by ribs that
work like a brace, his torso is full of airbag-like
sacs to protect his vitals. It’s, uh…
I mean, it’s definitely memorable, as safety
campaigns go. Looking past the weirdness,
Graham does succeed in making you aware of
how vulnerable your body is — how unequipped
humans are for the dangers of modern life.
In the U.S. alone, an estimated two million
people are injured annually in car accidents,
and at least thirty thousand never make it
home at all. The ecosystem that humans have
built is so alien, so fundamentally different
from the natural world, it’s difficult to
say how evolution will react. It’s of course
highly unlikely we’ll ever look anything
like Graham, since evolution works on a very
different timescale than technological advancement.
But humans are still evolving — our bones
have gotten lighter as we’ve transitioned
to a sedentary lifestyle. The average body
temperature is dropping due to improved sanitation
reducing infections. Even in our controlled
modern environments, evolution is an engine
that can’t be turned off... …But perhaps
it could be sped up. Man After Man is a bizarre
artbook by Dougal Dixon that explores how
genetic engineering could create new branches
in the human family tree far sooner than evolution
could. Like our friend Graham, the work is
more of a surreal thought experiment than
something that holds together scientifically.
Over eons of genome manipulation, some humans
become multi-armed oddities spliced from multiple
bodies. Others become enormous blobs engineered
to be a source of food. Still others become
genetically altered beasts of burden with
these giant air-conditioner heads that are…
practical, somehow? Some of these modified
humans later evolve further via natural selection,
taking on even wackier forms. There’s a…
peculiarity to the art which has made it famous
online. The project would even get a spiritual
successor in the form of C. M. Kosemen’s
All Tommorrows — a take on genetically engineered
posthumans which is, in my opinion, more cohesive
both aesthetically and thematically. Yet for
all their eccentricities, Man After Man and
Piccinini’s sculptures are unsettling meditations
on humanity’s uncertain future — reminding
us that change is inevitable, and not always
pretty. Evolution doesn’t necessarily mean
advancement, and depending on the choices
we make today, we may not recognize ourselves
tomorrow. Fascination with future human evolution
isn’t anything new. Stories about humanity’s
successors go all the way back to the nineteenth
century — with works like The Time Machine,
by H.G. Wells, featuring humans separating
into a predator and prey species. A few decades
later, Olaf Stapledon’s novel Last and First
Men chronicled eighteen future human species
over two billion years. The book was adapted
into an experimental film in 2020 — which
depicts vast, black and white landscapes of
crumbling monuments as a narrator reads from
sections of the novel. They speak of elephantine
humans with long, twisting trunks; bear-like
humans who dwell in the wild; and telepathic
superbeings who build an empire that lasts
for untold millennia. The scope of Last and
First Men can be overwhelming, even exhausting
— a relic from an era where the chief limit
to how long humanity had to evolve was the
eventual collapse of the sun. But soon, a
new invention would fundamentally alter our
confidence in the future. Narrator: “A Nuclear
blast and the subsequent fallout will have
many adverse effects on life as we know it.
Intensive, prolonged radiation exposure may
transform those aboveground into decrepit,
rotting beings that have lost their ability
to reason.” Our vision of humanity’s future
often reflects humanity’s present, which
is why during the Atomic Age, fear of nuclear
devastation gave rise to a very unique type
of posthuman. Throughout the 50s and 60s,
sci-fi films about the far future depicted
the Nuclear Mutant – descendants of humanity
transmuted into inhuman brutes from exposure
to radiation. These post-apocalyptic humanoids
were often monstrous to the point of absurdity,
with radioactivity portrayed as an all-powerful
catalyst for evolutionary change. In the 1955
film The Day the World Ended, nuclear fallout
rapidly turns humans in, uh, whatever this
is. Yet beyond their silly appearance, Nuclear
Mutants gave a face to the existential threat
of atomic annihilation, turning abstract dangers
into something tangible that human survivors
could overcome. Narrator: “It is the unfortunate
truth that when you go above ground, you will
be faced with many post-nuclear nuisances.”
It’s notable that alongside mutants, most
Atomic Age apocalypses had survivors — pure,
unaltered humans descended from those who
took shelter in bunkers before the bombs fell.
The trope echoes Cold War attitudes towards
preparedness — implying that with a little
good old fashion preparation, you and your
family won’t have to become mutants come
the end of the world. The 1956 movie World
Without End epitomizes this concept, presenting
an Earth cleanly split between an advanced
group of beautiful humans who had the foresight
to take shelter when the bombs fell, and a
horde of surface-dwelling mutants who were
caught in the blast. The idea that all of
humanity might change or die out, that no
amount of preparedness might be enough to
protect the status quo, is rarely confronted
in such stories. You don’t see many radiation-born
mutants in modern media. There are exceptions
— especially in retro-future franchises
like Fallout — but that’s a series that
delights in recreating the tropes of Atomic
Age sci-fi. Most modern depictions of nuclear
devastation are more subdued and somber — perhaps
because real disasters like Chernobyl and
Fukushima have brought the reality of radiation’s
long-term effects further into the world-wide
consciousness. Radiation doesn’t produce
campy monsters. Its effects aren’t charismatic
— most mutations, if they occur, are quiet
and tragic. And there’s no conquering it
— not really. You can react — evacuate
and quarantine the best you can, but ultimately,
it’s a force, like a car crash, that humans
simply haven’t been evolving to survive.
One option for humanity’s future, perhaps
the first one that came to mind when you saw
the title of this video… is that we don’t
get one. That if the end of civilization comes,
it will be the type of ending that doesn’t
leave survivors. Nuclear mutants certainly
don’t seem like an optimistic vision for
future humanoids — but I think they are,
in a way. Because in order for there to be
mutants, there has to be something to mutate
— some form of humanity that endured into
the post-apocalypse. But what if we don’t
even get that? There’s an animated short
film from 1939 titled Peace on Earth that
depicts humanity’s total extinction with
shocking directness for its time. In the short,
the last humans perish on a grim battlefield
that echoes the imagery of World War I. A
remake of the film titled Goodwill to Men
was released in 1955, featuring an updated
atomic arsenal. At the end of both narratives,
after humanity is completely wiped out, a
group of cute cartoon animals crawl from the
wreckage and eventually take our place on
planet earth, evolving a society and building
a civilization from the helmets of fallen
soldiers. It’s so deeply bizarre, with a
huge amount of tonal dissonance — especially
since this was apparently shown to children.
Yet there’s an undeniable power to both
shorts, which convey the same theme of humanity’s
impermanence. Humans aren’t sacred, and
the world will continue to turn in our absence.
And as freaky as many of the posthumans are
that we’ve explored so far, this ending
to humanity’s story — though simple and
understated — is probably the one that unsettles
me the most. Turning into a monstrous oddity
might not be an ideal future… but it seems
better than turning into a fossil. Human extinction
as our evolutionary future can be better understood
by looking into our past. In the game Ancestors:
The Humankind Odyssey, you play as a series
of hominin species within the human evolutionary
lineage. And while not everything in Ancestors
is scientifically accurate, it is an exceptionally
unflinching look at the grinding slog that
is evolution. You die a lot in this game.
Like our ancestors, you are given almost no
instruction — the only way to figure out
which plants are poisonous and which animals
will try to eat you is through slow, agonizing
repetition. In the early stages your screen
will flash with images of gnashing teeth,
a representation of your primate brain being
overwhelmed by fear. If ever there’s been
a piece of media that captures our vulnerability
as a species and the randomness that we made
it at all, it’s this one… What the game
doesn’t capture — what it can’t capture
with its gameplay of continuous forward progress
– is that evolution isn’t just a single
line. There were other branches in the hominin
family tree — just three hundred thousand
years ago, as many as nine other species of
humans walked the earth alongside us, many
of whom may have been our intellectual equals.
And now, well, now there’s only one. We
know extinction is possible for hominins,
because it’s happened before. Homo sapiens
aren’t the rule… we’re the exception.
The concept of humans eventually fading out
like the other hominins is famously explored
in the 1968 film Planet of the Apes. Based
on a novel by Pierre Boulle, the film begins
with three astronauts landing on a mysterious
planet that is dominated by a group of advanced
apes, who regard their planet’s human population
as nothing more than mindless animals. Through
this inversion, the film investigates how
humankind has historically mistreated other
animals and each other. It’s a theme especially
highlighted by the ending, where — spoiler
alert for a film that’s over a half-century
old — it turns out the characters were on
Earth in the future the whole time. “Oh
my god, I was wrong - it was Earth all along.”
A question central to Planet of the Apes,
particularly the recent prequel films, is
whether or not humans are capable of peacefully
coexisting with another intelligent species.
It’s a question that, tragically, may have
already been answered. We can’t definitely
prove the extent to which Homo sapiens were
responsible for the extinction of our fellow
hominins… but we do know that their disappearance
correlates very closely with the spread of
our ancestors. The ‘villain’ of the original
Planet of the Apes claims humans are a destructive
and territorial species, that violence is
intrinsic to human nature. And while one wants
to push back, to point at how far we’ve
come and say ‘no, we are more than just
violent animals, we are special and we are
going to make it’ — it’s hard not to
look at all we’ve done, the weapons we’ve
created, and wonder. Wonder if the last hominins
Homo sapiens will destroy… will be ourselves.
An equally harrowing vision of the future
is that humanity’s own evolutionary successors
will — in a bitter twist of fate — be
the ones to wipe us out. This patricide model
is prevalent in the wave of telekinetic sci-fi
films that surged in the 1970s and 80s. In
these narratives, humans born with telepathic
or other related abilities often come to see
themselves as the next phase in evolution
— and seek to eradicate or change the rest
of humanity. And the results are often cataclysmic,
with many films in this subgenre ending with
the ushering in of a new age. How these posthumans
are able to manipulate physics is a question
rarely answered with anything approaching
actual science. Probably the wildest explanation
comes from the more recent film Lucy, where
the main character develops the ability to
do… pretty much anything by using more than
10% of her brain. It’s an interesting film
visually, but as many of you are probably
aware, humans already use more than 10% of
our brains — we use the whole thing. But
while the science of these films is often
dubious, the premise of strife between humans
and posthumans seems far more plausible. In
the modern era, the idea of the superhuman
is probably most associated with the superhero
— who contrasts with other models of the
posthuman in various ways. The typical superhero
is an expectational individual preoccupied
with aiding a larger population of ordinary,
un-special humans. Rarely is there a fear
of replacement, because the superhero is an
outlier, unique — not here to usurp Homo
sapiens but instead a benevolent superbeing
sworn to uphold the status quo. Exceptions
to this model exist, with the most famous
probably being the mutants in the X-Men franchise.
These characters are quite explicitly a new
form of hominin, and due to their frequent
marginalization, many mutants in the series
wish to avoid or outright replace humanity.
Scientifically, these mutants are, of course,
fairly implausible. If mutations actually
worked like this in nature, it would be impossible
to even go outside, because the animal kingdom
would be full of mice with laser eyes, or
fire-breathing tigers. Yet the theme of conflict
between humanity and what comes next — both
in this franchise and across sci-fi — follows
a precedent set by our own evolutionary history.
It is a fitting twist of fate that humanity’s
successors might treat us the same way we
treated our hominin relatives. If in a theoretical
future superbeings came into existence, we’d
have to hope they weren’t like us... Yet
there is a final alternate path that sci-fi
proposes — for humans to step outside the
flow of evolution altogether and advance to
a new phase of existence through technological
augmentation. Next to severe mutation or extinction,
casting off the weakness of flesh for the
purity of metal might sound like an appealing
option. The idea of ascension via technology
has been around since the dawn of cinema.
The 1927 silent film Metropolis explores the
concept of resurrecting a human in the form
of a machine over a decade before the first
programmable computer. Mind uploading and
artificial immortality have long been cornerstones
of sci-fi — and are still widespread today.
It’s an alluring concept. Technology is
already changing what it means to be human.
If you’re someone who wears glasses or uses
the internet, you are, by some definitions,
already a semi-artificial posthuman — your
sense of self tied to a piece of technology.
Of course, both in sci-fi and the real world,
not everyone has equal access to new tech,
which is a key reason most techno-futures
aren’t as glamorous as they first appear.
One of the most striking depictions of such
a future comes from the video game Signalis,
which stands as one of the more enigmatic
yet moving pieces of sci-fi in recent memory.
The game centers on posthumans called Replikas
— human neural imprints downloaded into
the bodies of androids. It’s an imperfect
process — with the artificial minds suffering
breakdowns represented by sudden, bold flashes
of text and shifting patterns. The gameplay
feels equally unstable, glitching from retro
survival-horror, to first person puzzles,
to long cutscenes — all the while overwhelming
you with these flashes of blurred text. If
the game Ancestors simulates having the mind
of an early hominin, Signalis simulates having
the mind of an artificial posthuman that is
breaking down with equal forcefulness. At
one point the game overwhelms your senses
with a rapid-fire montage of classical oil
paintings. At another, just when a pivotal
action sequence is about to start, you instead
get text saying ‘violet scene missing,’
like your memory is short-circuiting. I’m
not going to pretend I understand everything
Signalis is getting at — frankly, I don’t
think anyone does. But I think it — like
most works of techno-posthumanism, has a healthy
amount of skepticism when it comes to technological
ascension. The next phase of humanity may
very well be artificial, but no path into
the future is without serious potential drawbacks.
In the end, it seems that every option for
the future of human evolution — both natural
and artificial — could be its own type of
catastrophe. While making this video, I kept
expecting to find more optimistic visions
of humanity’s next stage, but for the most
part, across sci-fi, there are shockingly
few positive examples of what Homo sapiens
might evolve into. And maybe that’s a serious
oversight. As something largely out of our
control, evolution can be frightening, but
I think it’s important to remember that
change — while unavoidable — doesn’t
have to be negative. And if we ever want to
improve, we need to start imagining what a
better future could look like... As always,
thanks for watching. If you enjoyed this entry,
please lend your support by liking, subscribing,
and hitting the notification icon to stay
up to date on all things Curious. See you
in the next video.